[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat permettre aux
pharmaciens de délivrés sans ordonnance
certains médicaments normalement
prescrits par des médecins elle c'est
l'objectif d'un amendement déposé dans
le cadre du projet de loi de santé
parmi les arguments avancés répondre à
l'enjeu de la désertification médicale
et désengorger les urgences solution
efficace pour certains mesure dangereuse
pour d'autres la proposition divise
pharmaciens et médecins généralistes
pour en parler
deux invités ce soir docteur pierre lévy
bonsoir vous êtes médecin généraliste et
trésorier du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins à des yvelines en face de vous
yorick berger pont soir bonsoir
vous êtes pharmacien et vice-président
de la fédération à des pharmaciens
d'officine d'île de france
ah merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
cette invitation
alors à partir du 18 mars prochain le
projet de loi santé sera discuté dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale
dont le fameux amendement du député la
république en marche thomas meissner
elle si le texte est adopté le
pharmacien pourra donc délivré et des
traitements actuellement prescrits sur
ordonnance dans le cadre de pathologies
simples du quotidien engine cystite ou
encore conjonctivite et yorick berger
coppens et vous de cette mesure dans une
bonne chose c'est une bonne chose
maintenant
la question qui se pose c'est comment ça
va se passer puisque l'on peut pas dire
on va éviter la case médecin puisque
c'est pas le but c'est surtout et avant
tout soulagé le patio qu'il ait une
réponse immédiate quand il n'y a pas de
solution est évidemment le mettre dans
le parcours de soin pour qu'il revoie
son médecin et qui est un réel suivi
donc c'est vraiment pour apporter une
solution
le soulager et que ça se passe dans le
meilleur des mondes
d'une manière générale cette idée ne
réjouit pas trop les médecins pourquoi
bien donc des messages les médecins sont
prudents il n'est pas question d'opposer
médecins et pharmaciens ce piège crois
que ce serait la pierre des pierres des
visions on nous sommes à une période de
transition du système de santé avec une
évolution collaborative c'est à dire que
dorénavant il y aura ce qu'on appelle
des communautés professionnelles de
territoire de santé qui a ceci en fait
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
et ou médecin nous disons simplement que
la prescription par les pharmaciens de
certains médicaments nécessitent une
concertation très étroite entre les
professionnels eux mêmes et on trouve
dommage qu'au moment où on met en place
un système on se voit balancer excusez
moi l'expression
une idée comme ça qui va tomber
qui va tomber sur nous et qui si elle
n'est pas réfléchir autres
professionnels risquent d'aboutir à des
catastrophes
c'est un peu ce qu'on a vu après à un
engouement pour les prêts de la
délivrance de médicaments devant un
comptoir c'est-à-dire et sans ordonnance
et maintenant on s'aperçoit et de plus
grande autorité du gouvernement aussi
qu' il ya des problèmes au niveau de la
délivrance de ces médicaments parce
qu'il ya des effets secondaires d'un
médicament et a toujours des effets
secondaires et doit être prescrit dans
des conditions bien précises
après avoir fait un diagnostic quand on
fait des études de médecine
on commence par un interrogatoire on
continue avec un examen clinique
on s'aide avec des examens paracliniques
et on finit par prescrire justement vous
parlez des études alors je crois qu'il
ya six années des tués dans pour être
pharmacien si je ne me trompe pas neuf
années pour pour être médecin informe du
riche en informations donc ne peut est
capable tout de même de parler de ses
effets de ces effets secondaires alors
le rôle du pharmacien complet notaire
effectivement celui du médecin
mon confrère médecin parlait de
diagnostic nous le met le pharmacien
on pose pas de diagnostic puisque c'est
le rôle du médecin
en revanche quand il pathologie on
connaît le médicament qui correspond
qu'il faut adapter avec la pharmacologie
nuance les effets secondaires et ses
confrères médecins par les oxydes
prescription on n'est pas là dans le
rôle de données attention et puis c'est
pas ce qu'on veut si on n'est pas là
pour prescrire un médicament
et c'est là où ce que vous dites trouve
son sens et que on peut pas lancer
quelque chose comme ça et puis ouvrir la
boîte et zir bombe et débrouillez-vous
non il faut que ce soit vraiment encadré
et aucunement se substituer au rôle du
médecin il est vraiment notre rôle est
d'enfin moi je le vois comme ça et comme
une ensemble de mes confrères apporter
la solution qui va soulager de passion
évidemment on va l'orienter mais on va
jamais posé un diagnostic puisque c'est
pas notre métier et on n'est pas fort
mais justement
vous êtes donc formation en officine
quand un client vient pour vous voir par
exemple je sais pas un samedi après-midi
pour une cystite et que vous ne pouvez
pas finalement lui lui donner de
médicaments comment il réagit il ya deux
problématiques soit il le patient ou
l'appelation bien souvent prend son mal
en patience et à temps soit ça va pas
elle va aux urgences et puis ça induit
tout ce qu'on connaît les attentes
l'engorgement des urgences c'est vrai
que sur c'est un des arguments justement
avancée par le député avec fait que donc
les pharmaciens puissent prescrire ces
médicaments c'est désengorger les
urgences que justement les personnes par
exemple j'ai donné l'exemple d'une
personne qui a une cystite conjonctivite
jeu victime ans c'est ce dont on parle
maintenant donnez donnez un antibiotique
le but ce n'est pas de donner une
antibiotiques à chaque fois qu'il ya une
patiente qui se plaint mais c'est
derrière de comprendre pourquoi elle a
un don il a besoin d'un antibiotique et
qu'elle revoie son médecin évidemment
pour faire des tests complémentaires
nous encore une fois je le dis on est là
pour soulager on n'est pas la fin dans
l'immédiat on est là pour apporter cette
solution évidemment ça permet de prendre
un petit peu plus de temps pour aller
voir le médecin mais il est obligatoire
que cette patiente revoit le médecin
évident autre argument aussi c'est de
répondre à l'enjeu la désertification
médicale où on va le voir justement sur
sur cette carte
j'te par exemple département des
yvelines est particulièrement concernée
avec de nombreuses zones d'intervention
prioritaire ce sont des zones où l'accès
aux soins est déficitaire que
répondez-vous au dr levy à cet argument
justement que ça puisse justement
permettre de lutter contre avant tout ce
que dit mon confrère information est
vraie c'est une cystite ça recouvre pas
certain nombre de pathologies
ça peut être une listed banal surtout
pour quelqu'un qui connaît pas le
patient et ça peut être le symptôme
d'une maladie beaucoup plus rares ou
pyrénées fried
enfin mon corps et des choses beaucoup
plus graves ceux d'orly kane il faut
surtout pas prescrit un antibiotique
d'anglais mais faire à nos cv eu un
examen site aubry théologique des urines
donc si vous voulez je pense que le
député qui a déposé ce projet cet
amendement ne réalise pas malgré qu'ils
soient médecins parce que il était
médecin ne réalisent pas que c'est pas
ça qui va résoudre le problème de la
démographie médicale sûrement pas la
démographie médicale on ne résoudra que
justement en changeant de système de
santé pour permettre aux jeunes qui ont
envie d'exercer de façon différente de
le faire et donc de s'installer plus il
faut pas prendre le problème à l'envers
on est en train de prendre le problème
il ya moins de médecins
on va trouver d'autres solutions
exactement comme on vous l'a fait pour
les permis de conduire avec les postiers
quoi je veux dire c'est quand même c'est
totalement aberrant il faut résoudre le
problème en le prenant à la base c'est à
dire il n'y a pas assez de médecins
pourquoi il ya pas assez de médecins
parce que ceux ci ne veulent plus
exercer comme ça et que on leur donne
des comptes des conditions d'exercice
qui soit plus confortable et qui leur
permettent d'avoir envie de faire de la
médecine générale
et là on aura à nouveau des médecins il
ya des personnes aussi qui vont sur
internet par exemple pour acheter des
médicaments
qui sont normalement prescrit sur
ordonnance est ce que justement le fait
d'autoriser les pharmaciens à prescrire
ces médicaments
justement ça n'aurait pas ce problème
aussi je fais même conques les mêmes
constatations les mêmes conclusions que
mon confrère pharmacien c'est tout après
concertation il n'y a pas de problème
encore une fois actuellement on est dans
une période de concertation justement
pour ce projet de santé et pour le
fameux plan du de monsieur lacombe ma
santé 2002 donc c'est le moment ou
jamais de se concerter mais c'est pas un
problème de parlementaires dans cet
amendement par exemple donc le
pharmacien pourrait prescrire des
médicaments si pour une angine est ce
que justement un pharmacien est capable
justement de dire une pas qu'une
personne quand une personne vient le
voir kylie kylie une angine il existe
des tests pour reconnaître ce type de
pathologie après je pense que le fond du
problème fin de la question comme vous
lisiez c'est vraiment ce qu'on peut
faire dans le cadre d'un patient pour
sécuriser et pour le pour lui répondre
immédiatement
c'est vrai que c'est un travail avant
tout deux profils de santé pour trouver
la citation la situation qui
conviendrait le mieux la solution
apportée exemple l'origine est un
excellent exemple une origine ça peut
être n'importe quoi ça peut aller de la
leucémie qui commence par une angine à
une mononucléose infectieuse dans
laquelle il faut surtout pas prescrit un
antibiotique parce que à tous les cons
prescrit déclame hawks il est le patient
paie rh leur racheter carrière
monumentale
ça peut être aussi une vie road alors là
peut-être que justement le rôle du
pharmacien
ça pourrait être de faire simplement le
test est mis à la disposition des
médecins mais diamant c'est rien du tout
pour rentrer à la maison avec du
paracétamol et puis a même suscité voilà
et si c'est bâclé rien là il faut encore
une fois c'est un problème d'adaptation
du traitement ou diagnostic précis pas
que ranger une angine c'est un symptôme
ouais c'est pas une maladie est-ce que
aussi cet amendement ne viendrait pas
finalement légaliser ce qui se fait déjà
dans la pratique
cinq des fois si on connaît bien son
pharmacien ça peut arriver que le
pharmacien prescrivent à un médicament
qui normalement est sur ordonnance
ça se fait dans la pratique vous parle
effectivement des dépannages
effectivement le savoir ce type
d'approché bien connaître son passion
c'est pas sûr du patient tout venant et
puis c'est vrai qu on a aussi un lien
avec les médecins de notre entourage on
les appelle ça peut faire gagner du
temps c'est sûr mais ça doit pas devenir
une pratique
et puis eux
qui est une dérive c'est surtout ça moi
je trouve sincèrement que cette cet
amendement est une bonne chose
maintenant il faut un cadre
ce cadre doit être discutée entre les
professionnels de santé les médecins les
pharmaciens
parce que nous on connaît nos limites
connaissent leurs limites
et puis tout mis bout à bout ça doit
aller dans le sens que encore une fois
du patient et de gagner du temps et de
résoudre des problèmes mais comme vous
l'avez dit ça résoudra pas le problème
de démographie médicale
ces bilans à cette émission touche
bientôt à sa fin on va conclure docteur
lévy faut-il laisser les pharmaciens
prescrire certains médicaments sur
ordonnance après concertation entre des
professionnels et dans le cadre de
l'élaboration des futurs modes
d'exercice qui sont les communautés
territoriales de relationnel de santé
finalement cette loi donc ils
discutaient à partir de la semaine
prochaine
viens trop 3 rapide en une rafale eu en
fait finalement
d'abord nommé le français ministre la
ministre est parfaitement consciente de
ça le ministre va avoir du mal à aller
dans ce sens
enfin sans concertation je veux dire
enfin d'appliquer bêtement à l'abandon
comme ça donc c'est pas le genre de
plusieurs je pense que tu as les
médecins et aussi merci en tout cas tous
les deux d'avoir été présent ce soir
voilà c'est la fin de deux sets puis
débat voulien un conclure un mot pour
conclure sinon 5 secondes
aucun souci effectivement la ministre de
la santé est consciente de ces choses là
c'est d'ailleurs elle qui avait retiré
les produits à base de codéine qui était
en vente libre il ya vraiment une
volonté de sécuriser le
le médicament je pense que son rôle
c'est aussi d'accompagner pour ça
fonctionne mieux toujours dans le temps
le bénéficie passion merci en tout cas
d'avoir suivi cette nuit de débat on se
retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]